[Music]
that must have been some of the material
okay pause
yeah that must have been some of the
material one of the other writers
because i don't remember writing that
one
i feel like he uh he he was looking for
a little more from uh
that macaulay culkin joke i bet you
if he'd known that's what it was he
might not have circled back but you
gotta admire
his circle back it was pretty flawless
yeah pretty soon yeah yeah i mean his
that segue back into that into macaulay
culkin it's like
oh wow that's amazing he's able to he's
like
he can manipulate the audience he's got
them in the palm of his
of his semi-gloved hand palm of his
[ __ ] hand
uh let's press play speaking of the
super bowl which we were before earlier
before we spoke about macaulay culkin
so just take your mindset back to that
remember the game the big game that
nobody
well i don't give a [ __ ] about it i'm
sure the whole [ __ ] world
does but i don't care i don't care
i exceed all the new advertisements
online already they
premiere that monday thursday and friday
what's the point of watching the game
nobody's going to die
but people like this super bowl
and according to the good folks at
grubhub
mention bane and get 10 percent off
at grubhub delivery
go to the grubhub app and just enter
bane of mine let's pause for a second
of my subsistence
yeah let's pause you know i don't think
that's a real uh
promotion by the way probably not but
you know
comedian funny they're always saying
crazy [ __ ] lies
yeah yeah he's just joking probably
whatever they can do to get a laugh it's
really
working down there there's no doubt
we're learning about this guy i'm sure
grubhub is just appreciative for the
free shout out
so yeah then not a lot of people know
about them
this guy's getting the word out and we
press play
okay so i was talking about the people
at grubhub
who've paid me nothing i didn't get
anybody from the
i'm more of a postmates person but
i didn't write this joke clearly bought
it off the internet
and i guess grubhub is more prominent
wherever this writer most from most
people nebraska
[Music]
everywhere else in the world that see
the door dash or
uber eats
crop pub
i'm gonna have to look them up ask
chiefs
[Music]
anyway
i'm throwing a little side shade
once mega search giant now fallen at the
feet of google
according to the people that grubhub or
substitute your favorite food service
delivery app
according to the people on a at the
at a food delivery app
they are estimating that super bowl
sunday will be the biggest food delivery
of the year
do you know what we call food delivery
where i grew up
when a rat ran across your face when you
were sleeping convenient fresher no need
to
tap am i right ladies and gentlemen the
tip is the worst
part makes it so expensive
i know that one's not
it universal be off privilege goodbye oh
they're all from the phone second
problem yeah yeah
you know i don't think he understands
the idea of a of a topical
though and what that is is that you know
like a writer
a comedy person they will go and they'll
find a real story in the press
yes and they'll report the headline of
that story right
and then the part after the setup
is no longer true it's the only the
setup has to be true but then so this
whole thing was corrupt but maybe that
would there was an article somewhere
where somebody saw
that growing up was making that claim
just then you're going to just as we
start to pull apart and analyze
that's this guy it's a long road to go
down to uh
go down on andy for a joke written by a
guy on the internet
like that's true you don't have to
defend that joke right i'm not defining
the joke i'm more
just analyzing how you know bane while
funny how did we get here
steam seems to have a lot of a long way
to go still in terms of understanding
some of the ropes in the
in the bits he's green so that's so cool
um yeah let's let's [ __ ] get back in
there
yeah we've got a lot to be got a lot to
get through and we press play
can't believe someone wrote grubhub
still no another joke bombed
who here uses grubhub
no one right
you sir you look like a doordash man yes
of course you are
and you you're just young enough to be
an uber eater
you your postmate malone himself
neither one of you are using grubhub
unbelievable forty dollars i paid for
that joke
if he had used the term postmates it
would have been worth fifty
speaking of cheap businesses the
standard hotel on the sunset strip which
had
famous investors like leonardo dicaprio
is going out of business
or another way to put it
once upon a time in hollywood the
inception of a hotel was a titanic
investment that is now
departed
did everyone see the rat run across the
railing
at the end of that joke profound
or stupid you tell me
pause wow wow man i mean this guy's
working real local to talk about the
closing the standard hotel and [ __ ]
that one's stunning i mean that's kind
of an international story because it is
a
that hotel is in seven cities around the
world it's true it's true
that's to me it's it was a local story
but you're right other people have heard
of this hotel they're like hey [ __ ] you
hollywood we've all heard of the
standard
how many people have stayed there you
ever stay there i did
no but i live here me too i and i didn't
even stay at the standard overnight we
uh rented the hotel
one day me and my wife and had sex there
like and then left and came back to our
home which is literally five minutes
away
it was probably took longer to wait for
your car at the valet than it would have
been to
walk or [ __ ] that's that was
10 years into the marriage now we're
over 20.
wow yeah [ __ ] popping down the hotel
to the hotel for a quickie don't really
[ __ ] cut the mustard anymore
particularly in the age of coven it's
like ooh you want to pop by the hotel
like there's
she's like there's nobody here let's
just [ __ ] here in the house and she's
like i don't even want to [ __ ] so like
why are we talking let's watch something
stream that
and then we stream something
what was the attraction that the that
the sign was upside down
um yeah i don't know why we went
but we also took a soundtrack from that
place like you've not took it they sell
sold the cd that was like the standard
and we put it down it's making the audio
go crazy oh i'm sorry i was touching
something i was touching the monitor oh
the computer how weird you heard that
yeah let me see i'm gonna do it again
you hear that yeah that's so weird what
does it sound like it sounds like you're
scratching
like get out of here hold on let me try
now it doesn't work because you wanted
to i know god damn i thought we were on
to something i'm like oh my god
i'm gonna be a brand new diplo of this
[ __ ] there it is
ah i'm back it was a little something
i'm a musical genius
um wait what were we talking about uh
the standards upside down uh luggage you
said you had a soundtrack from that
place
i took a cd from that place because we
when we were there we had sex
we put the cd on and then when we left i
was like uh you know what let's [ __ ]
take this with us it was all right
because we never
played music during sex i used to love
listening to music while [ __ ] um but
jennifer was like how am i supposed to
concentrate
if i'm listening to lyrics and so then
for years it was just
you know quiet well that's because it
was always the the uh soundtrack to
south pacific
yes we probably got something else going
on
there was nothing like a dame i put out
i think she just never wanted to hear
music and [ __ ] and so for years all i
heard was
okay move move [ __ ] back
help us so then one day because we went
to the standard hotel we got that
soundtrack and we have like that
literally no lie
has become for years now our
go-to sex music music
so i'll miss the standard i know bane
was making fun of it but like
it plays it will forever play a role
in my life and i had no idea that uh
that [ __ ] leonardo dicaprio had money
in it man so
next if i ever meet him i'm gonna be
like you know what bro
i've been [ __ ] to the same cd for the
last
15 years or more and that i know exactly
what he's going to say
what's he going to say security
[Laughter]
um you think you're funny andy let's
listen to bane wait wait one more thing
i got a question
yeah he keeps talking about spaying
paying all this money for these jokes
and i have yet to see dollar one no
i don't know you take it up with him i
don't want to get between you guys
okay that's fine that sounds fake now
this guy does not sound stable
i wouldn't i wouldn't be [ __ ] dealing
with it how do you collect from them
exactly don't send them jokes anymore
man but then again lose your phone
number if you do
um all right we press play
does everyone despise ryan seacrest as
much as i do
because if so this next joke is going to
rock your
dome
ryan seacrest is selling his beverly
hills estate for
85 million dollars
what the [ __ ] what am i doing wrong
what am i doing wrong with a man like
seacrest has an
85 million dollar mansion
i once held gotham ransom
can't make my rent
[ __ ] all he does is speak
it's not like he cures cancer he [ __ ]
hosts
85 million dollars it's disgusting
here goes the punchline spokesman for
seacrest released this statement
seacrest out
seacrest out and i'm out of my mind 85
million
dollar home for what what does he
do
i'm a worldwide terrorist i fought the
batman to a standstill i broken his back
it's a good thing i'm a bernie bro money
doesn't mean that much to me
i have principles and standards that's
what i have
let ryan seacrest have a giant 85
million dollar home
the home in my heart is priceless
priceless
wow i mean did he forget
he was at a comedy club that one really
uh resonated with old bane i mean it
resonated with me i thought that was
kind of beautiful
this guy's like a maybe like a lenny
bruce man he may be
funny but he's also got some [ __ ] to say
he's a thinker
this comedian it's not the jokes he buys
those are pretty bad but it's the things
the points he makes between the jokes
that's where the humor is i think
we'll see i don't know um let's press
play
oh great another nutrition study
am i right isn't that how we all feel
every time when you read about another
nutrition study oh great
well a new government survey finds that
most americans don't eat enough fruits
and vegetables every day
somebody spent money to do that probably
85 million dollars they could have
bought seacrest's house
pricks in a related study the sun came
up this morning and water is wet
because nobody likes fruits and
vegetables but you can have processed
foods
pre-sweetened with high fructose corn
syrup
or sugar cane sugar if you buy things
from whole foods
which i can't because i'm not to ride
[ __ ] seacrest in my
85 million dollar mansion that i can
just
sell it's not his only home
that's the sickening fart
turns my stomach to see that amount of
wealth in the hands of one man for what
ugh
let's talk about baseball shall we
everybody loves the
great american game baseball
well yankee stadium is where they play
the great game of baseball
at least they used to for now the new
york health officials have started using
yankee stadium as a vaccination site for
all new york city residents
not because it's convenient mind you but
because there are so many free
leftover needles from a rod's time
on the team
i'm sure one of you will explain that
joke to me one day
not a sports aficionado
this is about some sort of juicing
scandal
i guess that would stand to reason let
me go with another punchline
now the only thing that you will get
sick from matthyaki stadium
is the food because as you know yankee
stadium consistently ranks at the bottom
of for food quality and safety
national standards and testing
you didn't read that on google news well
apparently you don't read google news
when you take a [ __ ] everybody you
should
if you're sitting there anywhere spend
the time to expand your mind
you'll remember it because it rhymes
there's a third punch line
the weak minded
due to a jews as a vaccination site i
shall refrain from blowing up yankee
stadium until july
2022 ladies and gentlemen
try to independent when there is no
[ __ ] building
don't send some kid out there to sing
i'll tell you right now
that didn't work here in gotham it won't
work in new york city
i will level yankee stadium
if my demands are not met by this
government
or the batman one second
hey who would
[ __ ] sake what's that
oh i'm sorry is my comedy interfering
with your marriage
sir
my god the incivility man's incivility
to man i'm up here practicing a
time-honored art form
bearing my soul bravely stepping out
and speaking to power and you're going
to sit there the audience and what
bicker with your wife
do it on your own time
two drink minimum and a 20 cover charge
pick her on your own time
am i right people leave him alone oh
[ __ ] you
why don't you go suck his dick while his
wife watches
man wow
i mean you know it's a time-honored
tradition andy
for a good comedian to heckle back in
the audience but that
didn't sound like heckling as much as
the bile just yeah no it goes he doesn't
have the he doesn't know how to ramp up
to the big stuff he just goes straight
he goes from zero to 100.
i gotta i gotta see if he how he
recovers from this how do you bounce
back after something like that
press play well now it's my turn on him
and play
i see everybody is up my ass about being
real
so i better take it back to the safe
jokes this one's about the world's
tiniest reptile
hopefully you'll be able to handle this
[ __ ] children
here we go blow up animal humor
a chameleon the size of a seed was
discovered in madagascar last week
scientists are saying it's the world's
tiniest reptile
but today david spade said hey
what about me
i just rocked you with my david spade
impression
the twofer he's got a show on netflix so
he's current again so this is not an old
reference it's fairly new
any chance i get to throw a shot at
david spade
oh that's what makes this job worth
living
oh let's see speaking of
kooky celebrities
professional talker and part-time
filmmaker kevin smith
you all heard of this clown
this two mask wearing [ __ ] clown
that's coming for me look at this mask
and i'm mocking his
has been discussing his fasting regimen
on his popular podcast
while he can go much longer he regularly
goes on
86 hour fasts
you know what we called an 86-hour fast
back in the pit
a three-day weekend
sometimes the guards would go home and
they wouldn't come back till monday
we'd starve until we ate one another
i fed on the flash of another man
cooked it myself chewed it
like so much chicken
the guards didn't care nobody cared
there's no oversight in the place like
that
thank you honey oh my god what the hell
is happening in this club
is that the waitress
yeah don't forget to tip her when the
show's over
i don't know what that said i'm walking
good for you hey man it's me kevin smith
have you been looking for all my old
podcasts the ones i started recording
back in 2007. well guess what i found
them they're all hiding
in that kevin smith club see all the
video you've never seen including
exclusive movies and live
shows you want some swag that kevin
smith club is making pins
and miniature versions of my old scripts
if you want to be involved in the least
exclusive
most inclusive club on the net join that
kevin smith club
now's your chance to club kevin smith
i'm getting the red light ladies and
gentlemen
telling me that they're walking oh
let's see did you hear the one about the
saint louis jail revolt more than 100
prisoners in the st
louis detention center riot and lighting
fires
throwing furniture out the windows i'm
shocked
and angry and saddened that no one
thought to invite me
you know what's always good
weather weather humor everybody loves a
weather joke
meteorology gets right to the heart of
the funny bone
so with your permission
he said sarcastically i would like to
speak with you about the polar vortex
the northern united states is
experiencing the
to experience freezing temperatures as
low as
-25 degrees 25 degrees below zero
in a phenomenon called the pool of
vortex
yet some areas could go up to a warm 60
degrees by next week
minus 25 to plus 60 in a week
that's not a polar vortex i
call that a bipolar vortex
because the swings are as emotional and
as wide as those that have to deal with
bipolar disorder do you understand
[Applause]
i hate doing comedy for you plebes
but it's the only way to get my own
amazon comedy special
speaking of amazon
the founder of amazon.com jeff bezos
announced this week he is stepping down
the ceo
of the company
sad
he said he's stepping down to spend more
time violating the privacy of his
customers
alexa can you play
everything i've said for the last five
years
uh there's an alternate punchline just
in case you didn't like that one
although i thought
that rocked but here's the alt
you know a lot of people like his
decision and to that amazon replied
people who like
jeff bezos stepping down may also like
the hamilton beach mixmaster 9000.
you see if you've ever shopped on amazon
you know that is very funny very funny
i love it when we can goose consumer
culture
we hold an audience up to you the we all
the audience build a
the audience and show you yourselves
and you are thoroughly disgusted
and wisely so look at these meat puppets
you say to yourselves
don't they realize how futile it all is
well
welcome to my world welcome to my train
of thought
grab on tighter i'm going to throw you
out the caboose of this train of thought
oh speaking of train of thought the ipad
mini right
make it smaller we said apple said oh of
course
now give me a thousand dollars
we forgot to say make it smaller and
free
we won't be fooled again will we
apple has announced plans to release a
new ipad mini that is faster
has a longer battery life and is much
bigger
a bigger ipad mini ladies and gentlemen
i believe that's called
an ipad
no
don't you understand how the man is
[ __ ] you repeatedly
you don't have to upgrade every time
they tell you to
i'm still working on an iphone 3.
you people are [ __ ] sheep
ugh speaking of individuals who disgust
those at large
woody allen there i said it
woody allen hbo has announced
new explosive documentary footage series
on
the director woody allen
they're expected to start out appealing
to the adult us
market and then almost at the end
oh boy
and almost at the end expand into the
youth
market however there was a modifier for
youth
controversial to say the least and even
though i've
held cities ransom i'm not going there
buzz oh yeah
looks like bane looks like we know where
the line is with pain you found it
if you don't you don't trucking race
stuff i guess that's his [ __ ]
kryptonite
i didn't think it was i i did i didn't
think it was an appropriate
fight i think he would have seen that
joke on on uh
late night tonight yeah yeah
well he he you know what might have
happened he might have watched
um the documentary about britney spears
where they talked about how like
everybody on late night saying [ __ ]
about her made like you know her life
harder and [ __ ]
it sounds good maybe he's like oh man
[ __ ]
yeah i don't want to take a shot at
woody allen his life's hard enough
um i got here i told you there were
people
other writers that were contributing to
this and i didn't like a lot of their
material
hey man [ __ ] it's not the material
it's the guy it's in the hands of the
man who's saying it
put your gland in the hand of the man
who wears the breather
put your gland in the hand of the man
that
[Music]
[ __ ] i wasn't prepared for the rest
where's the breather and then
put your man in the man put your gland
in the hand and the man who
behind the city who talks like
who talks like this put your
gland in there why am i saying glad
that's not the [ __ ] lyrics at all
leave its hand if you put your gland in
my hand you're not getting it back
i'll wear it around my neck a necklace
full of [ __ ]
that will send a message
speaking of sending a message this is my
final joke of the evening ladies and
gentlemen oh oh oh wow
well they didn't flash the red light 45
minutes ago
but i say
[ __ ] who's ever next i've i'm on a roll
clearly i was on fire this evening it's
a record night for me with a hot seat
ladies and gentlemen give yourself a
gigantic round of applause for
getting their smart material
okay ladies and gentlemen the closer in
three parts
one punch one set up three punch lines
how about that
we'll we'll drag this out as long as we
possibly could
it's like the end of the carol burnett
show i'll answer your questions until i
yank my ear and they pull me off
which sounds far filthier than i meant
it but i am hoping to get pulled off
tonight
anybody interested meet me in the bar
afterwards
we can get to know one another and
perhaps exchange bodily fluids
as adults do
jamaica ladies and gentlemen the island
nation of jamaica
they're running out of marijuana i
never thought that would happen am i
right due to heavy rains that followed a
drought
plus a dwindling number of farmers
jamaican agriculture officials
have announced that the island of
jamaica
is running out of marijuana
well if you're looking for the seventh
sign of the apocalypse jamaica running
out of wheat has got to be it
the end of the world will not come with
a bong
but with a whimper
i switched that up the the
the end of the world will come not with
a whimper
but with a bong yes
i felt better i know it takes the quote
out of
the proper order but i always thought
that the bang
should have been the last part of that
line whimper was not a
argue but still i think my way is better
here's the second punchline in case you
didn't like that
the case that was too heady for you
it's the stanford joke here comes the
use the stanford punch line here comes
the ucla punchline
rather than soften the blow they decided
to make the announcement
blunt
and uh the third punch line that is
general audiences
authorities are asking the farmers for
help
it will be a joint operation
boom goes the dynamite ladies
i know i've rocked your world have you
had a good time
this evening
that sarcasm one lone woo
oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] comedy club
this horrible [ __ ] city and everyone
who lives in it
damn them all to hell you've been a
great audience ladies and gentlemen
thank you so much my name is bane
keep smiling keep shining
knowing you can always count on me
for truth that's
what i am for
i'm just winging this last bit
trying it out on its feet if you will
it's workshopping it
help me out here [ __ ] laugh would you
i tried so hard and you'd never laugh
and then i kill and kill again
don't you see if if there was laughter
there would not be someone
[Applause]
deaths is so hard to find the things i
say humorous
humor me and save a [ __ ] life
what's wrong with me
what's wrong with me
pause all right andy people at home
can't see the clip
but he is just sinking to the floor like
he's deflating
and literally sobbing on a comedy club
stage yeah it's it's uh
that's what i said it's either andy
kaufman or it's something a lot
a lot darker all i know is um
[Music]
clip ends there but as we all saw on
in the news uh he killed everyone after
that
yeah every one of them including that
guy and his wife which was really
sad because they seemed to have a real
good marriage going she said she was
walking but
people get into fights all the time and
[ __ ] i thought they were going to make
it but
not anymore they didn't make it to the
hospital they died no
no i guess we buried the lien on that
one too but i don't think people would
have enjoyed it as much
yeah now you got to ask yourself did you
laugh
did you not laugh because it wasn't
funny or did you not laugh because you
knew the man
killed all the people who also didn't
laugh
um boy oh boy
well to be fair we did give an hour of
silence for the victims of his uh
there's nothing i love more than
listening to [ __ ] bane
do his thing man plot his trade [ __ ]
redefine a genre that i
love and thought i knew insanely well
you know i thought
i knew every way there was to tell a
joke but
bane teaches me something new all the
time
now he's closing with that's what
friends are for
yeah which i mean what do you think the
likelihood is that he actually cleared
that
like he's paying for that he's a comic
he doesn't have to he's allowed to do
you think there's a parody there he gets
under the uh
fair use absolutely for sure that's what
friends are for yeah yeah he's gotta
yeah [ __ ] yeah okay
to settle that that was my big question
about everything so yeah that settles it
i don't think
most comics should close with a song
unless it's a song of their own
composing right
like [ __ ] picking a popular song it
could always go wrong like one day that
song won't be popular anymore right
yeah or do you pick some song that like
yeah exactly i mean it's
something that you've been like oh my
god i gotta do it every single time or
if you end
up oh i want to say good night and
they're like oh do the song you're like
all right all it takes is a pitch pipe a
song and a smile
you know it's just like not you can't
just you can't keep that
is that a real song it is you try
harmonizing and after a while
when you have all the songs memorized
you buy
four coats and get organized
i told you i was a member of the society
for the preservation of barbershop
quartets in america
what was the song about that song it's
about being in a barbershop quartet
does do barbershop quartets that any of
them sing songs
like about i got some [ __ ]
and it was wet
about as well
did they ever do hot songs yeah they did
i think i think people could really like
get into barbershop quartet if it just
got nasty man
yeah well there's a whole like you don't
like the songs you hear are the songs
they can play on the radio
but then when you see these guys it's
like they do a lot of material about
what it's like to be on the road
you know i mean women go nuts for those
straw hats and the uh
stripes their songs are just like
um uh i'm on the road cause i'm
a singing man boom boom boom i'm getting
blown by
every single fan boom boom boom
we should do a whole album [ __ ] yeah i'm
telling you that's what would make
barbershop
huge as if you were like you know
i ate her [ __ ] like it was cherry pie
but then she took a [ __ ] and i almost
died
i'm telling you it could be like you
remember how big the jerky boys were for
like a minute
i know it's the second time i referenced
him i think in the show but
i think we could be like the next jerky
boys with [ __ ] dirty barbershop
quartet songs because nobody's expecting
that
it's an innocent kind of singing but you
know
put with dirty words it could be fun and
interesting again for the first time
people might like barbershop quartet if
you were talking about like
uh my dick is longer
and then you end it with a big you know
irish tenor my
[ __ ] you know stuff like that totally
[ __ ] you know
i could tell you how to do the business
and [ __ ]
his [ __ ] is long
[Laughter]
it's a lost art form [ __ ] dirty
barbershop quartet
they get thrown out of every competition
the moment they start singing
barbershop quartet
[Music]
you're wet for john get him off the
stage
what why um i'm telling you that's an
album right there
yes it is start writing the filthiest
[ __ ] barbershop princess song you
could sing
we can write the music you write the
lyrics we got done and done we can
record the hell bum bum
every song is exactly the same just the
lyrics are different and more and more
filthy as time goes on
absolutely um yeah no i'll [ __ ] write
the lyrics no no prob
but that's a project we'd get done even
in the middle of pandemic
get like four really good voices and
[ __ ] and and uh
record them and then we just layer them
up and
then [ __ ] rock like put that [ __ ] on
[ __ ] band camp where people like oh
my god
have you heard the [ __ ] um
the bawdy barbershop quartet
the body barbers that's what we call us
his body say it yeah body is nice
because it's marketable people like bob
i'm body whenever i [ __ ] go out i
feel body too
the body barbers man colon body barbers
colon
naughty barbershop quartet okay
the naughty barbershop quartet got
through you don't mean like an actual
colon there's like a just the two dots
right put an actual colon in there man
that makes it even dirtier
before they even hear a [ __ ] note
they're like look at that [ __ ] is that
an [ __ ] on that [ __ ] record
place right in the center too um the
body barbers
um like imagine you
hear the body barbers rock uh
wap whap what ass [ __ ]
that way
it tastes so goddamn good
i like that what has [ __ ] in my
neighborhood
oh you're so crazy i'm telling you dude
it's a good idea
everybody thinks that's a good idea
write to
andy mcelfresh at thank you kevin smith
education kevin smith club at twitter
you'll find him because he's got a
series of pictures of bothered birds who
are like
like they just got caught jerking off
and let them know that you want to hear
that album because andy can make it
happen he's got the barbershop quartet
just needs to come up with music i'll
come up the filthiest [ __ ] lyrics
imaginable
so filthy that i bet you'd be hard for
your friends to [ __ ] pull it off and
sing
because they'd be like i touched her
nipple
that's a nipple that's where we get to
the real hardcore words
like vulva and butthole
um did you have fun kids was that enough
comedy for you
well i'm afraid it's gonna have to do
because that's
that's all that's all we're given yeah
send every podcast with an apology
yeah taking what we're given because
we're [ __ ]
podcasting for a living
um if you enjoyed today's episode
particularly bane's routine
i don't know why but i feel like we
should thank professor
andrew uh and with such a left-handed
compliment
i doff my cap to you sir thank you
um he is not a real professor but don't
worry about that
um i was too focused on the uh just the
left this the underhandedness of the
comment but
yes not a real professor you were busy
that's right i forgot that new music for
the barbership for the body barbers man
i'm telling you give me more than boom
boom boom boom although we could do nine
songs that are just the same with
different lyrics
i grabbed her vulva and then she grabbed
my dick boom
hi my wife walked in and waved what's
that like
during a podcast she gave me a note says
i'm walking out
of this marriage i was like oh sure
um there it is ladies and gentlemen you
have a silly good time i know i did man
if you had a silly good time you give it
up for the [ __ ] man over there to man
with the plan
the man who is a fish andy mcelfish
ladies and gentlemen
thank you um not a real fish not a
refresh
[Music]
and that ladies and gentlemen is
edumacation for this week i'm kevin
smith
and i'm andy calvert um and you
have not only been decimated you have
been
[Music]
educated